No longer is Russia fighting Ukraine but the whole West,
nothing that might even be taken as a sign of dissent is allowed in Russia right now.
It's massively early to say Russia is,
you know,
a dying power.
Evan Goshko is not a spy.
He is a talented resourceful,
dedicated professional journalist.
He doesn't belong in jail.
It's not where he belonged,
he belonging in this newsroom.
He is being held hostage essentially and through no
fault of his own.
When Wall Street Journal reporter Evan Gko was detained in Russia in March and charged with
espionage.
He was simply doing his job,
the journal,
his colleagues and the Biden administration deny the allegation.
It's utter rubbish.
Evan was doing what reporters do.
A 31 year old American born journalist with Russian heritage.
He has spent more than five years covering Russia.
He joined the journal last January a month before Russia invaded Ukraine.
Evan is an editor's reporter.
It's the reporter that you dream about.
We knew from the time he joined us last year that we have a winner.
I just remember this incredible excitement about Russia.
He was telling me about the books.
He was reading,
get to get to know the country better.
He was incredibly excited about the prospect of reporting from that.
He believes that being on the ground is really important and we all benefit from
that.
Evans reporting took him across the former Soviet Union,
including to the Belarus Ukraine border where he was the only American reporter who could see the
first wounded Russian forces being taken home.
He profiled Russian dissidents and Kremlin supporters alike and he traveled beyond
Moscow to bring readers important information contributing to wsj's podcasts and
videos.
Along the way,
they are worried,
extremely worried about what I think everybody has seen as an increasingly
erratic government in Moscow.
So I had the privilege of interviewing Evan for a video about Kazakhstan.
And first of all,
it was very clear right off the bat that his knowledge of the former Soviet Union was extremely
deep.
He knew it like the back of his hand.
So when I was in Kazakhstan,
I spoke with a lawmaker and he invoked this Siberian fairy
tale.
So the story goes that a bear and the and this chipmunk were friends one day,
this bear was in a really good mood and it tries to pat the chipmunk on the back,
but you know,
it still has claws and it scratched the chipmunk and that's why these chipmunks or why chipmunks now have
these three stripes on their backs.
This parliamentarian's point was that,
you know,
Kazakhstan will be friends with Russia,
but it's still a bear and they need to wash their backs.
Colleagues who work closely with Evan say he has a deep affection for Russia and even
felt blessed to have accreditation from the Kremlin to report.
There always spoke about his love for Russian culture,
tradition,
literature and thought that,
you know,
as a person who is from a Russian background,
he could actually be more um more effective in telling the Russia
story.
There are not many people with the talent and the language skills and the knowledge of Russia
record and the documents to be able to go there and work there,
who can do it as well as he can.
And he,
he understood this,
he understood the great privilege that he has in covering this country.
I mean,
everyone will tell you he's just a really kind of a fun person to,
to be around.
I think that's one of the things that makes him so good at his job because he's someone that
people kind of enjoy being around.
It must have been after midnight,
you know,
the and uh and everywhere was closed.
So we just stood on the street talking about what was happening about our experiences,
you know,
from three generations perhaps of Wall Street Journal Russia coverage,
just sharing um what,
you know,
what we'd seen,
how things have changed,
how things were the same.
Um And,
and that was,
that was,
that was a special moment I remember with that reporting on the ground in Russia grew
more perilous as the war raged on and on March 29th,
Evans fellow correspondents knew something was wrong after I hadn't heard from him
for about seven hours.
I got worried shot.
It didn't go through and then I reached out to our security team.
The next morning,
Evan was seen being escorted from court by Russian officers.
He's facing a possible prison sentence of up to 20 years.
It's the first time Russia has brought a spy case against an American reporter since the Cold
War on April two Secretary of State Antony Blinken called his Russian counterpart to
demand Evan's release.
I can't even begin to imagine what,
what he must be going through.
But uh he's uh he's,
he's,
I think he's,
he's really strong um mentally and physically.
So,
um you know,
I hope he will um persevere Evan is not the kind of guy who wants to be the
story.
Evan wants to tell the story about Russia about what's happening in Russia.
Um And I can't wait for him to get out and start telling that story again.